>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, JOHN
SOLOMON, GREAT REPORTING ON A
LOT MORE COMING.
THANK YOU.
NOW THE DEEP STATE, THEY ARE
CLEARLY IN PANIC MODE COULD ALSO
TONIGHT, SO TOO ARE THERE BEST
FRIENDS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FOR NEARLY THREE YEARS, PELOSI,
SCHUMER, THEIR RADICAL BAYS,
THEY HAVE RELIED ON NOTHING
OTHER THAN LIES, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THE POLITICS OF
DESTRUCTION.
THEY HAVE BEEN ON A MISSION, AND
THAT IS TO TAKE DOWN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AT ALL CAUSE.
NOW, THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO
IMPROVE THE ECONOMY, NONE.
NONE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN, THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY THAT MAKE
THE COUNTRY GREAT.
NO SOLUTION FOR IMMIGRATION.
NO VISION FOR MORE PEACE AROUND
THE WORLD.
INSTEAD, THREE LONG YEARS, ONE
BIG LIE, CONSPIRACY THEORY, A
ROTHWELL, NEW MEXICO, LEVEL
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
BUT NOW THE GIG IS UP.
WE HAVE FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE ALL
CLEARED PRESIDENT TRUMP OF THE
SERIOUS CHARGES LEVELED AGAINST
HIM ON HIS CAMPAIGN.
NO COLLUSION, FACTS.
NO OBSTRUCTION, FACT.
NOW THEY COLLUSION HOAX DEAD AND
BURIED, ABSOLUTELY ZERO RECORD
OF ACCOMPLISHMENT FROM ANYBODY
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW GRASPING AT
STRAWS, AND NOW, OH, LET'S GO
TO A FIFTH INVESTIGATION, MAYBE
WE WILL MAKE IT AN IMPEACHMENT
THREAT.
OVER WHAT?
UNSPECIFIED, FANDOM CRIMES, THAT
THEY CAN'T EVEN SEEM TO DESCRIB
DESCRIBE.
THEY ARE LITERALLY DEMANDING
WHAT WOULD BE A FIFTH SEPARATE
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
RAGE, HATRED, PSYCHOSIS, NOW
GOVERN THIS NEW RADICAL,
EXTREME, DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
TODAY, RIGHT BEFORE AN IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE MEETING PLANNED
AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI, SHE HAD PLENTY OF
TIME TO CONTINUE THE LYING AND
RECKLESSLY ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT
OF A COVER-UP.
BY THE WAY, WHILE YOU WATCH
THIS, THINK, A COVER-UP OF WHAT?
>> WOULD YOU BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW THE FACT?
I WOULD BELIEVE THAT NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS ENGAGED IN A
COVER-UP.
>> Sean: OKAY, ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF COVERING UP A CRIME
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
COVERING UP EXACTLY WHAT,
SPEAKER PELOSI?
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES COVERING UP?
INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE FBI, BOB
MUELLER, HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE,
BIPARTISAN SENATE PANEL, ON THE
SAME RUSSIA COLLUSION LINE, ALL
CLEARED THE PRESIDENT.
YET SPEAKER PELOSI -- BY THE
WAY, SHE IS ONLY SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY.
SHE HAS TO NOW CAPITULATE TO A
RADICAL BASE LED BY THE REAL
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, AND THAT
OF, CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND HER FRIENDS IN
THE RADICAL LEFT.
PELOSI, OF COURSE, NOW ACTING ON
THE INSANE DICTATES, YES, GIVEN
BY FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMEN.
TO BASH OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF,
JUST MINUTES BEFORE WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A BIPARTISAN,
IMPORTANT MEETING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
PRESIDENT IS DONE.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS,
COOPERATION, NO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, ENCOURAGED EVERYONE
TO TESTIFY PAID 1.5 MILLION
DOCUMENTS, EVEN ANSWERED
MUELLER'S QUESTIONS.
HE'S DONE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE A PUNCHING
BAG DAY IN AND DAY OUT THERE
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT RIGHTLY
FOUGHT BACK IN A HUGE WAY.
HE SHOULD DO IT, HE DID DO IT,
AND ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
PRESIDENT WALKED RIGHT INTO HIS
MEETING WITH PELOSI AND SCHUMER,
CALLED THEM OUT FOR THEIR
UNETHICAL CONDUCT, AND ENDED THE
MEETING, AND WALKED INTO THE
ROSE GARDEN, WHERE HE DELIVERED
THESE PRETTY POWERFUL REMARKS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WHOLE THING WITH RUSSIA
WAS A HOAX.
AS IT RELATES TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND MYSELF, IT
WAS A TOTAL, HORRIBLE THING THAT
HAPPENED TO OUR COUNTRY.
THEN I HAVE NANCY PELOSI GO OUT
AND SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ENGAGED IN A
COVER-UP.
NOW, WE HAVE HAD A HOUSE
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE SENATE INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE INVESTIGATIONS LIKE
NOBODY HAS EVER HAD BEFORE.
WE DID NOTHING WRONG.
I WALKED INTO THE ROOM, AND I
TOLD SENATOR SCHUMER,
SPEAKER PELOSI, I WANT TO DO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I WANT TO DO IT MORE THAN YOU
WANT TO DO IT.
I WOULD BE REALLY GOOD AT THAT.
THAT IS WHAT I DO.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN'T DO IT UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO GET THESE PHONY
INVESTIGATIONS OVER WITH.
>> Sean: YEAH, IT IS BEYOND
SAD.
IT IS FRANKLY PATHETIC, THESE
PHONY INVESTIGATIONS, SIX
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THAT IS ALL
THIS DEMOCRATIC RADICAL
SOCIALIST PARTY HAS.
PELOSI, SHE HAS BEEN SPEAKER NOW
FOR NEARLY SIX MONTHS.
THEY'VE ACCOMPLISHED NOTHING.
SHE TURNED ON A COMPROMISE ON
DACA, COMPROMISE FOR DREAMERS,
SAID BUILDING WALLS ARE IMMORAL.
SHE WASN'T SAYING THAT IN
OBAMA'S SECOND TERM.
BLOCK ANY ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THE FAILURES THAT EVERYBODY
PAYS MORE, LOST THEIR DOCTOR,
AND BY THE WAY, DON'T HAVE ANY
CHOICES ANYMORE.
OBAMACARE, SHE AND HER FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, THEY PLAYED A ZERO
ROLE IN WHAT IS NOW THE BEST
ECONOMY WE HAVE SEEN IN DECADES.
IT IS ROARING.
AMERICA'S ENERGY INDEPENDENT,
DEMOCRATS, NO ROLE MILLIONS OF
NEW JOBS CREATED, NO ROLE
WHATSOEVER APPEARED 1.7 MILLION
JOBS AVAILABLE, MORE THAN
PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE SC
PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE SR
PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE SN
PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE SG
THE BORDER, NO ROLE WHATSOEVER
APPEARED TO RADIO, NOTHING.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING FOR IT
YOU CAN'T EVEN SHOW UP TO A
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
MEETING WITHOUT LAUNCHING A VILE
ATTACK AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
FIRST?
THIS IS NOT PELOSI'S FIRST
RODEO, THOUGH.
SHE KNOWS HER IMPEACHMENT
FANTASY IS BAD POLITICS, IT
WON'T WORK, AND SHE IS
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
CONTROLLED BY THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST BASE AND HER PARTY.
AS I SAID, SPEAKER PELOSI IN
NAME ONLY.
PELOSI DOESN'T APPEASE
OCASIO-CORTEZ, CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR, AND OTHERS, SHE KNOWS SHE
IS OUT OF LEADERSHIP.
THAT IS WHY AFTER TODAY'S
WHITE HOUSE MEETING, PELOSI
DOUBLED DOWN ON DUMB AND THESE
UNFOUNDED ATTACKS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, AND SAID SHE WOULD
PRAY FOR HIM.
>> WASN'T REALLY RESPECTFUL OF
THE CONGRESS AND THE WHITE HOUSE
WORKING TOGETHER.
HE JUST TOOK A PASS.
IN ANY EVENT, I PRAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND I PRAY FOR THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
THE FACT IS, IN PLAIN SIGHT, IN
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN, THIS
PRESIDENT IS OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE, AND HE IS ENGAGED IN A
COVER-UP.
AND THAT COULD BE AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> Sean: ABOUT THE LEADER?
WOW.
ALL RIGHT COME ON TWITTER, THE
PRESIDENT, A SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR
PELOSI BIRD RIDING "DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP IS TEARING THE U.S.
APART BUT I WILL CONSIDER YOU TO
SET RECORDS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NANCY, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRAYERS.
I KNOW YOU TRULY MEAN IT."
KIND OF CRACKED ME UP.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB, THREE LONG YEARS
TRYING TO CON YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
MAKE NO DOUBT, THEY LIED TO YOU.
THEY BUY THE TIME.
THIS IS NO LONGER THE PARTY OF
JOE LIEBERMAN, EVEN A TIP
O'NEILL, STRONG LIBERAL,
MASSACHUSETTS.
INSTEAD, IT IS NOW THE PARTY OF
RADICAL SOCIALISTS, LIARS,
CON ARTIST, AND CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS.
THAT IS WHO THEY ARE.
THAT IS ALL THEY OWN PEER WHERE
ARE THE SOLUTIONS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
APPROPRIATELY ENOUGH, YOU'RE ONE
ONE-TIME SAVIOR, MICHAEL
AVENATTI, IS ONCE AGAIN IN
SERIOUS LEGAL TROUBLE TODAY.
YES, HE WAS CHARGED WITH
STEALING MONEY FROM STORMY
STORMY STORMY STORMY'S BOOK
DEAL.
ALSO FACING SEPARATE EXTORTION
CHARGES ON 36 OTHER FEDERAL
INDICTMENTS OF PERJURY, THEFT,
FRAUD.
FOR MONTHS, BY THE WAY, AVENATTI
WAS BEGGING TO COME ON THIS
PROGRAM.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND WE NEVER GAVE HIM A SERIOUS
PLATFORM.
HE NEVER DESERVED IT.
WE'VE LOOKED AT HIM, SAID,
FRANKLY, WE SAW THROUGH HIM FROM
THE GET-GO.
THIS CHANNEL LITERALLY CALLED
OUT HIS FRAUD OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
BY THE WAY, WE STILL GIVE HIM
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE,
SOMETHING HE NEVER GAVE JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH.
BUT THIS WASN'T THE CASE ON
OTHER NETWORKS.
FOR OVER A YEAR, THE MEDIA MOB
WORSHIPED AT THE ALTAR OF
AVENATTI.
GIVING HIM HOURS AND HOURS OF
AIRTIME, HIS VIEWS, FRAUDULENT,
UNCHECKED ACCUSATIONS.
THEY WERE GIDDY ABOUT EVERY
INTERVIEW.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY STORMY
DANIELS LAWYER AND MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
THANKS FOR MAKING TIME HERE AT
>> STORMY DANIELS LAWYER,
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
MICHAEL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
>> THE ATTORNEY FOR STEPHANIE
CLIFFORD, A.K.A., STORMY
DANIELS.
MR. AVENATTI, WELCOME TO "MEET
THE PRESS."
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI, THANKS FOR
BEING ON THE SHOW.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> MICHAEL, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THIS MORNING.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI JOINS ME
NOW.
>> LET'S BRING IN MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
>> STORMY DANIELS ATTORNEY, OF
COURSE BAIRD MICHAEL, WELCOME
TO.
>> HERE TO DISCUSS, STORMY
DANIELS ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
>> LET'S GET REACTION FROM
STORMY DANIELS ATTORNEY, MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
GO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: [FAKE LAUGH]
LISTENING PEOPLE WHO PROMOTED
THE RUSSIAN LIES AND CONSIDERS
THE THEORIES AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT COME EVERY MINUTE,
SECOND, OUR EVERY DAY.
THE SAME PEOPLE CALLING FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OVER PHANTOM CRIMES,
THE SAME I-BELIEVER-S.
PROTECTING HILLARY FROM REAL
OBSTRUCTION, REAL INTENT, REAL
UNDERMINE CRIME.
THE MEDIA MOB'S RECKLESS BIAS
HAS NEVER BEEN MORE PALPABLE
THAN TODAY.
IT IS CLEAR NOW MORE THAN EVER,
AS WE HAVE SAID IN '07 AND
BEYOND, JOURNALISM IN AMERICA,
IT IS DEAD, IT IS VERY PAIRED WE
WILL HAVE A LOT MORE COMING UP
YOUR OF THE HOUR APPEARED AS I
SAID, WE HAVE A LOT OF GUESTS
COMING UP TONIGHT.
BREAKING NEWS, WE HAVE A BIG
STORY TO COVER.
THE HOUSE RANKING INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE MEMBER DEVIN NUNES,
AND A LETTER TO PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THE CONGRESSMEN, HE IS NOW
URGING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
DISCUSS HILLARY'S DIRTY,
RUSSIAN, BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER WITH HIS BRITISH
COUNTERPART, WRITING "I
RESPECT THE REQUEST THAT YOU ASK
PRIME MINISTER MAY ABOUT THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT'S KNOWLEDGE
OF THE STEELE DOSSIER AND
WHETHER THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT
TOOK ANY UNILATERAL ACTIONS
BASED ON INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
STEELE AT THE REQUEST OF ANY
U.S. DEPARTMENTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT APPEARS THE
RANKING MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE HAS REASON TO
BELIEVE THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT
MAY HAVE ALSO USED OF THE DIRTY,
RUSSIAN, PHONY, LYING DOSSIER,
HILLARY PAID FOR, AS A BASIS TO
SPY ON A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
SO TONIGHT, THE QUESTION
REMAINS: DID THEY COORDINATE
WITH OUR OWN AMERICAN INTEL
AGENCIES TO SPY ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, WORKING FOR THE TRUMP